bonjour bastille relâche au bg merci
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france on va aborder la question du
mali avec cette phrase du président de
la république dans le jdd dimanche qui
menace de retirer les troupes du mali si
le pays avait la tentation de
l'islamisme radical
je rappelle que vous êtes membre de la
commission de la défense nationale
quel est votre avis sur la question
l'écouté cette cette phrase c'est l'aveu
pour le président macron de l'échec de
sa politique
cela fait maintenant 8 entre sommes
engagés au mali cela fait des milliards
que nous y déversons pour cette
opération militaire 57 villes françaises
des centaines de vies malienne qui ont
été perdus pour résultat lamentable
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus
de groupes armés qu'il n'y en avait il
ya huit ans l'horaire d'influencé est
plus importante
la sécurisation du mali est dramatique
et en fait on en revient à la vraie
question
cette question que nous mettons en avant
depuis maintenant plus de quatre ans au
niveau de la france un souci c'est la
question de la démocratie parce que
cette opération mali elle n'a jamais été
validé par le peuple français ni par ses
représentants le parlement n'a jamais
fauté sur l'opération par câble et sur
le maintien de nos troupes pendant huit
ans dans ce pays
elle n'a jamais été discuté par le
peuple malien lui-même et on le voit le
prologue démocratique au mali il ne se
révèle pas aujourd'hui à cause de ce
nouveau putsch de ce deuxième putsch
militaire en neuf mois
le problème démocratique est beaucoup
plus ancien la réélection du président
yves beck a soutenu par la france alors
même que tous les observateurs disent
que ces élections n'ont pas été honnêtes
et
juste et bien ce c'est la démonstration
que la le peuple malien n'est plus
maître de son destin et donc à partir de
ce moment là évidemment il n'y a pas de
solution possible au mali sans véritable
dispositif démocratique de retour du
peuple au pouvoir
on va écouter justement cette
déclaration du chef de l'état et
poursuivre justement cette question de
la présence française au mali et coûté
au président malien bendo qui était très
rigoureux sur l'étanchéité entre le
pouvoir et les djihadistes j'avais dit
l'islamisme radical au mali avec nos
soldats sur place
jamais de la vie il y a aujourd'hui
cette tentation au mali mais si cela va
dans ce sens je me retirerai est-ce que
là elle la menace de l'islamisme radical
au mali avec ce deuxième couche
des militaires est une est une vraie
crainte fondée pour la france pour les
militaires français sur place qui
vraisemblablement n'a plus de véritable
interlocuteur pour lutter contre le
terrorisme au sahel en tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est que les le premier
coup d'état qui a eu il ya quelques mois
avaient été très bien je vais dire pour
les intérêts de la france vue par tels
que des manuels macron avait été très
bien gérée vu que ce sont des personnels
plutôt francophile qui avait été qui
avait été mise au pouvoir et donc qu'ils
continuent et les relations avec la
france telle qu'elle était avant
là ça semble être être différent donc
est-ce que dès que ce ne sont plus des
personnes très francophile qui sera au
pouvoir il ya crainte de l'islamisme
radical
je pense qu'il est trop tôt pour le dire
aujourd'hui
parce que la situation intérieure
malienne n'est pas encore stabilisé donc
s'avancer là dessus est très très
compliqué je pense plutôt qu'il s'agit
d'un coup de pression d'un coup de bluff
du président parce que la réalité c'est
que
depuis maintenant plusieurs années avec
la présence insoumise nous demandons un
plan de retrait c'est à dire quelque
chose d'organisé que l'on fixe des
objectifs militaires atteignable que
l'on puisse contrôler ses objectifs et
qu à partir de ce moment là on puisse
dire voilà nous avons rempli notre
mission donc nous partons cela n'a
jamais été évoqué réfléchis par le
gouvernement indique président est là
aujourd'hui 10 de que l'on va partir
mais il est impossible de partir du jour
au lendemain du mali donc là il s'agit
d'un coup de bluff
mais d'un coup de bluff ou on sait que
le président ne peut pas le faire de
toute manière parce que rien n'est prêt
pour remplacer la les armées françaises
aucune force internationale le
gouvernement n'a pas pensé ou n'a pas
travaillé avec l'onu pour essayer de
redonner de la puissance à cette
organisation et trouver une solution
rien de tout cela n'a été fait donc à
partir de ce moment là il s'agit plutôt
à mon sens de paroles en l'air et d'une
on va dire du de diplomatie du porte
voix qui ne n'aura pas de conséquences
et surtout qui décrédibilise la parole
de la france qui discrédite la parole de
la france car qui va croire de telles
menaces quand on sait que nous ne
pouvons pas retiré de troupe du jour au
lendemain autre fait marquant dans
l'actualité politique une députée de
votre parti la france insoumise
bénédicte taurines qui a été jeté au sol
par un policier
c'était lors d'une manifestation
d'agriculteurs au siège parisien de pôle
emploi ce week end
on va regarder cette vidéo et jeux
recueillir est votre réaction après
alors on le voit très bien bénédicte
taurine porte l'écharpé tricolore donc
il ya peu de doutes sur son identité que
ce que vous avez à dire sur cette scène
c'est dramatique c'est le symbole même
des dérives organisée par le préfet
l'allemand à paris avec les styles aux
appels les forces de l'ordre qui crée le
désordre on le voit bien là il ya un
principe constitutionnel clair c'est que
les députés sont inviolables et d'une
certaine manière sacrée parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on garantit la la démocratie
c'est à dire que nous garantissons que
les droits de l'opposition ne seront pas
bafouée par l'exécutif et la houle on le
voit le policier voit très bien qu'il y
avait eu des chats et jette à terre une
personne qui représente la la république
et donc c'est on voit bien les dérives
factieuses qui peuvent exister au sein
des au sein au sein de la police
et rien n'est fait pour y mettre un
terme que que café préfet l'allemand
qu'a fait le ministre darmanin pour pour
cela il a ouvert une enquête ouvert une
enquête confiée à l'igpn l'igpn on le
sait aujourd'hui est un organisme qui
blanchit les les policiers pour
tout s'est fait de ces faits de violence
il n'y a pas de vraie enquête ou en tout
cas elles ne débouchent jamais sûr sur
rien donc le très très clairement il y a
là une démonstration de plus deux des
dangers pour pour la république avec ce
gouvernement qui est soumis d'une
certaine manière aux syndicats policiers
qui manifestaient devant l'assemblée
nationale pour faire pression sur
l'exécutif avec peu sur le législatif
avec le l'exécutif au mépris de la
séparation des pouvoirs
autre principe constitutionnel on a
vraiment l'impression que la
constitution elle-même les droits de
l'homme et du citoyen dérange ce
gouvernement et le préfet l'allemand une
enquête effectivement a été ouverte par
le parquet de paris je voudrais qu'on
regarde là est la réaction d'adrien
katniss le député du nord justement on
va parler de cette manifestation des
policiers il y en a qui disent que le
problème de la police c'est la justice
il y en a qui espère qu'une
manifestation fasse tomber les digues de
la loi et de la constitution
il y en a pour qui une élue en écharpe
tricolore ne représente rien y at il un
pilote à l'intérieur alors on le sait la
france insoumise n'avait pas participé à
ce rassemblement des policiers devant
l'assemblée nationale est ce que vous
pensez que c'est quand en quelque sorte
un acte de représailles
mais ça serait dramatique ça serait
dramatique que dit le membre d'un parti
d'opposition soit frappée et violentée
par l'exécutif parce que la police c'est
le bras armé d'une certaine manière de
l'exécutif et donc du gouvernement pour
pour leurs opinions
si un tel lien était été démontrée ce
serait d'une gravité d'une gravité rares
alors évidemment il faut aujourd'hui
qu'une enquête fasse la lumière sur ces
faits mais l'enquêté ne peut pas être
confiée à l'igpn qui on le sait
aujourd'hui n'est n'est absolument pas
en capacité de
de réellement bien traiter ces cas et on
le voit il ya aujourd'hui une vraie
menace sur les droits humains les plus
fondamentaux c'est la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen est qui
qui prévoit cette cette garantie pour
les oppositions qui prévoit des des
libertés et la séparation des pouvoirs
qui prévoit que la norme suprême c'est
la constitution et que c'est la loi
et aujourd'hui on le voit les syndicats
policiers ces organisations factieuses
et bien elle en appelle à abroger ces
lois boire même abroger ces
constitutions qui pour elles sont sont
le problème non les problèmes de me que
rencontre la police aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas la loi ce n'est pas la constitution
ce sont des manques de moyens ce sont
des moyens tels qu'ils ont été supprimés
par les gouvernements passent et qui
aujourd'hui en appel à des surenchères
sécuritaires qui a supprimé le plus de
policiers si ce n'est le gouvernement
républicain de sarkozy suivi par le
gouvernement hollande et le gouvernement
macron voilà ce que devrait demander de
véritables syndicat policier plus de
moyens plus d'effectifs les moyens
d'exercer leurs missions
pas d des menaces contre la justice
contre le pouvoir législatif et le que
le fait que le gouvernement ne fasse
rien c'est la démonstration ou d'une
complicité ou d'une faiblesse coupable
il nous reste quelques secondes bastien
la chaux votre réaction à ce qui s'est
passé dans l'est parisien une procession
catholique agressée alors qu'elle
manifestait la commémoration
de la tuerie des des prêtres de la
commune ils ont été agressés vous voyez
sur ces images par des personnes
cagoulées des personnes dites plutôt de
l'ultra gauche
quelle est votre réaction à ces
agressions jour je rappelle qu'à une
personne qui a été hospitalisée a dit
manière la violence quelle qu'elle soit
doit être condamné qu'il s'agisse de la
violence routière comme on a pu le voir
lors que ce soit la violence là la
réalité également c'est que nous la
religion n'a pas vraiment sa place dans
l'espace public
par ailleurs des pierres de grès dû
interdire cette manifestation selon vous
manifestation historique aussi en
quelque sorte oui mais écoutez la la
religion n'a pas sa place dans l'espace
dans l'espace public là la religion est
quelque chose de personnel
ces manifestations
donc quand on manifeste contre
l'islamophobie est ce que ça procède pas
de la même intention non là
l'islamologue l'islamophobie
c'est un cetain c'est un racisme il ne
s'agit pas de manifestations religieuses
les à mon sens la question à mon sens
les l'expression de la religion doit
s'exprimer dans les lieux qui sont
prévus pour cela dans le respect le plus
total delà de la liberté de religion
mais l'espace public doit doit rester
doit rester neutre au maximum et laïque
donc merci beaucoup bastien la chose
d'avoir répondu ce matin à nos questions
sur rt france